partout à tis les Gaulois ont débarqué
au château de broteuil les Gaulois mais
aussi les hommes préhistoriques les
dinosaures et même les spationot mais
tout petit les Playmobil se sont
installés le temps d'un weekend au
château de Breteuil pour le plus grand
plaisir des visiteurs il y en a pour
tous les âges on a beau même être très
très très adulte on retourne B enfance
c'est c'est vraiment c'est magnifique il
y a beaucoup de détails c'est vraiment
super beau il y a plein de choses à voir
on sait même plus où regarder tellement
il y a des choses à à voir il y a plein
de petits détails que ça part des
végétaux animaux que ce soit aussi les
costumes des détails rigolos des détails
historiques le thème de cette année au
fil de l'histoire c'est la 6e fois que
le château éelinois fait appel à
Dominique betthune pour réaliser une
exposition autour de la célèbre marque
de jouet allemande il y a beaucoup de
choses ici qui sont modifiées c'est des
Playmobil qui n'existent pas qui ne sont
pas vendu par la marque donc ce sont des
des objets collection qu'on a réalisé en
impression 3D surtout euh donc ça a pris
beaucoup beaucoup de temps donc il y a
des choses effectivement qui sont
dessinés à l'ordinateur auparavant le
château de bretoil a lancé les vacances
de la toussin des animations vont courir
pendant 2 semaines avec toujours de
nouvelles histoires